I grew up with it so I've read 1984
probably three years after it was first
published
I read brave new world around that time
in my life I read a book called of
darkness and noon which is actually not
speculative fiction or science fiction
it's is its life and the purges of the
Soviet Union but it read to me very much
like that that kind of book and I just
growing up in the 40s I was still in the
golden age of of sci-fi and I just knew
it
so I also did some work on it earlier in
my life and I guess I just always wanted
to write a book like that and the first
one that I wrote is called The
Handmaid's Tale and I wanted among other
things to try to solve the problem that
those kinds of books have which I call
the the tour of the garbage disposal
plant in which the person says to the
visiting character well in your day you
did this terribly inefficient thing but
now we have this wonderful garbage
disposal plant and there's a lot of
exposition like that and I wanted to be
able to tell the story like that without
those big chunks of exposition so partly
it was a challenge but partly it was
also a number of burning issues that
have now become even more burning and it
was the same with the maddaddam trilogy
which begins with Oryx and Crake and we
say the world of the future from within
a privileged environment our narrator
Jimmy is of that environment though not
good at it and in year of the flood we
move outside the privileged part of that
society into a pretty criminal level of
it which nonetheless contains the very
high mind and cult of the gods gardeners
and in this future genetic modification
is not the only
we're also in in an age of advanced
climate change for instance which will
bring with it a whole bunch of other
problems that people are just beginning
to think about and and figure out
yes my artifact is in fact this
wonderful hat which was made last year
for a performance of the era of the
flood when we were launching the book we
did performances that have music and
dramatic elements and narration the gods
gardeners recycle everything so we have
thought is twisted newspaper it's
cardboard this is plastic bags and we
have the little plastic bag bow at the
back and the Kingston Ontario production
of this thing they made all the costumes
and they've all got they've all got hats
like this since we're traveling to Japan
and recreating it all there I've got the
Hat with me
well in the year of the flood the
gardener's a green recycling group don't
use any technology that's their story
and the reason you don't use it is that
if you can see it it can see you oh it's
very leaky in that way and one thing
that people are using this kind of
technology for us is spying on other
people so security is a big issue if you
don't want other people to read your
emails don't send them number one